Minions… or monsters?
The new Amazon series “The Rings of Power”
portrays Orcs in a much different light than
the iconic film trilogy.
Keep watching to find out how faithful to
the original text they really are.
When you sit down to watch a live-action version
of a J.R.R.
Tolkien story, it's virtually guaranteed that
you'll see folks like Hobbits, Elves and Dwarves
over the course of the adventure.
Likewise, at one point or another, there's
going to be Orcs.
These twisted, brutal creatures oppose the
protagonists of "The Lord of the Rings'' on
multiple occasions, and make up the bulk of
Sauron's and Saruman's armies in climactic battles.
Peter Jackson's "The Hobbit" film trilogy
even features prominent Orc-lords Azog and Bolg.
The Orcs in the various movies are imposing
and fearsome-looking, and they hiss, grunt
and roar exactly like you'd assume.
However, in the grand scheme of things, the
live-action orc groups we've seen so far are
essentially just factions that happen to oppose
the heroes because they serve the villain,
and it's their literal job description to
do so.
Sure, as Boromir fatally finds out in "The
Lord of the Rings: Fellowship of the Ring,"
particularly strong Orcs like the Uruk-Hai
have been known to achieve major victories.
Still, by and large, orcs serve the same purpose
as Stormtroopers do in "Star Wars" movies
— they're unsympathetic cannon fodder for
the heroes to mow down by the dozen.
That is, until Amazon Prime Video's critically-acclaimed
"The Lord of the Rings: The Rings of Power" turned up.
The series doesn't take long to establish
Orcs as a true terror, and in doing so, the
show finally makes them as horrifying as Tolkien
intended.
Every Tolkien-themed live-action project has
managed to portray Orcs as creepy creatures.
However, "The Rings of Power" Episode 2 outright
turns them into horror movie villains by leaning
hard on their digging abilities, which Tolkien
has noted rival the Dwarves themselves.
These Orcs don't just look like slasher movie
monsters, either — they also play the part.
They provide copious jump scares.
They stalk terrified, hiding people.
And as Bronwyn and Theo find out firsthand,
they're extremely hard to kill when you're
not a powerful hero armed with rare and luxurious
weaponry.
Even well-equipped and trained Elven warrior
Arondir gets the scare of his lifetime as
he flees the terrifying enemies ... and then,
just when he least expects it, several clawed
hands emerge from the darkness and grab him
from behind.
It's horrifying stuff, and a very good take
on Tolkien's Orcs.
Out of all the different beings in "The Lord
of the Rings," they might just be the most
twisted, but they're still more or less cannon
fodder in the movies — which is far from
the unyielding monsters Tolkien wrote them
as.
The author wrote about Orcs and their creator
— Sauron's old boss Melkor, aka Morgoth
— in "The Fall of Gondolin":
"Their hearts were of granite and their bodies
deformed; foul their faces which smiled not,
but their laugh that of the clash of metal,
and to nothing were they more fain than to
aid in the basest of the purposes of Melko."
Now, which portrayal fits that description
better?
The unruly minions of the movies, or the ruthless,
stalking beasts in "The Rings of Power" Episode 2?
According to an IGN article about "The Rings
of Power's" Orc game, the feral and terrifying
version of Orcs we see in the show is a very
premeditated approach.
Executive producer Lindsey Weber said,
"We spent a lot of time talking about what
it would mean to be an Orc in the Second Age.
It felt appropriate that their look would
be different, part of a wilder, more raw,
Second Age Middle-earth, closer to where the
First Age ends.
As we meet them, they're not yet organized
into armies, they're a little more scattered
and they've been scavenging."
Weber also teased that the show will feature
all sorts of different Orcs, including female ones.
Interestingly, the unnerving effect of the
show's Orcs is so strong that even the actors
were thrown off by them.
As Lloyd Owen (who plays notable Númenórean
Elendil in the show) told Metro, the Orcs
legitimately creeped him out on set.
The actor said,
"You get a visceral reaction to it.
Which is rejection ultimately.
'I don't want to be around that.'"
Based on what we've seen so far, it's difficult
to imagine anyone wanting to be around the
show's Orcs for any amount of time ... but
from the looks of it, the people of Middle-earth
might not have any other option.